going back to when he talked about when
you faced uh anatoly karpov i think you
were what 21 22 years ago
prior to him who was the most
intimidating opponent you faced was
there anybody you faced where you were
you didn't know whether you were going
to beat them or not
no
you don't even remember it
no it's being it's not remembering it's
this you know carpool was of course my
nemesis you know this because we played
five world championship matches we spent
hundreds of hours you know
uh in front of each other at the
chessboard but again just going back to
what my mother told me it's it's about
you
so whatever happened in the game of
chess it was always you know
my own contribution i did well i won i
did poorly i lost but there's no one to
blame
so it's the
yeah i had tough opponents but i always
knew that if i could improve
i would win
when you faced them and you won you
became the champion what was that like
when you became the champion the first
time and
you were at the top of the world the
first time what was i feeling like look
i am
it's probably quite ironic that my first
memory of the moment being the world
champion it's i won my
last game against karpov game 24 1985 on
november 9th
so and next day there was a ceremony
award ceremony so and um
and even in my book even i just you know
i i i made it like an introduction
because with all these you know hugs and
kisses you know and gary
you know that so that's the uh i was
standing on the stage you know
you know just look at the pictures this
big hair
flowers l'oreal
and
all i remember it's it's then i was
approached by
a widow of one of the former world
champions ronald petrossian another
armenian so tigran petrossian was one of
my mentors
and she looked at me
it was a glimpse of sadness and she said
young man
i'm sorry for you
what
sorry for me i'm 22 i'm the best on this
planet the sky is the limit and she
repeated i'm sorry for you because the
happiest day of your life has just
passed
can you imagine to hear it at age 22
i i i have to admit i i didn't pay much
attention to that okay things happen but
then i you know it was it got it so
somehow it got stuck and
and i thought oh what was it a curse or
a blessing
because it could be a curse but also it
gave me reasons to prove her wrong
so just you know to do other things you
know just to make sure that you know i
could you know
push the horizon not only in the game of
chess and i stayed on top for a long
time but it's just do other things and
uh
and um i that's what that's what i
remember and i think it was a great
start
because it just it's it's made me
recognize that you know it's the you
know
you can you cannot seize the process of
exploration
and learning and um
again that's that's it's that's i think
we all
hear a lot of
advices
from
you know from right left and the center
but it's for us to pay attention it's
again to understand what matters most
i recognize that this warning
was sort of
like a greatest push into my future
from 84 to 05 you're number one
yeah
how the hell do you do that
no no you act like it's normal because
you're you like you've been you your
entire life but we are you know we're
every other sport no one's been number
one for 21 years how do you do that look
um
is it the game different is it your
discipline is it your wanting to prove
that lady wrong that said this is going
to be the biggest point highest point
for you is it your father's drive is it
your mom supporting you what was it
all together
you just keep keep counting
because keep counting because you need
it's this is a combination it's not just
one factor it's all about it's it's all
together plus many more but on top of
that is you know it's the it's the
something i learned is and that's the
that's again was very important lesson
it
goes beyond chess it's for business for
life for politics
if we lose the game
whether it's in chess whether it's
another sport whether in in business
deal or political campaign we know we
did something wrong and we have to go
back and we have to study
where we made a mistake
now if we want
naturally it's because we're great and
would like to celebrate
now i can tell you someone who stayed on
top for so long
perfect game doesn't exist if you won
for a simple reason because your
opponent made the last mistake
and it's most likely you also made
mistakes or inaccuracies
there it is they always know things to
improve and
i think one of the key elements of my
success was that i was relentless with
myself so i was brutally honest
so i looked at my games and i won many
more than i lost of course
and i knew that you know in order to win
next day i have to look at what i did
find my mistakes and come back you know
being again at the cutting edge
so what i figured out that if you are
challenging your own excellence you will
never run short of opponents
so that's that was simple so i i knew
that it's it's all about improving my
game even staying on top
because the moment you want to rest on
your
you are in trouble as it put in my book
success
is very often the greatest enemy of
future success
because it can blind us of course
we think we did it because because we're
the greatest and we can now just enjoy
life the moment you enjoy your life
you're done so if you like this sort of
short clip from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire interview
and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you